well I've been in movies that have been
nominated before but I but I've never
been this close to it so I don't have
anything to relate to per se I've just
kind of take it a day at a time but I'm
but I'm just excited for I want people
go see this movie I want people to go
see this story and and I think you know
Steven Rogers wrote an amazing script
and it's well directed and Margo kills
it and Allison kills it so it's just I
think any of that is just icing on the
cake well tell me about the scenes with
there were some really hard to watch
scenes with Margo what were the most
what was the most difficult scene to
shoot the most difficult scene as she
was definitely the gun scene that was
really hard just because it felt to be a
very pivotal moment in this in their
relationship in the script and also kind
of when everything was going crazy and
and yeah I'd circle that scene on my
calendar and like I was always tracking
it day by day to see how close I'm
getting says shooting that scene but
it's just what it was yeah I went well
and I'm happy about it did you ever meet
Jeff Gillooly or Jeff okay what was that
like uh it was strange it was strange
because you spend a few months kind of
researching somebody and then they kind
of appear before you and and you're
looking at and sort of in double takes
so to speak but he listen if I didn't
know anything about him if I had no
preconceived ideas or anything like that
I mean he seemed like a very regular guy
you know I mean it was it was
interesting to talk to him but I'm glad
I did because I was able to get a little
bit of insight as as to you know when he
was younger or how you know his life now
at 50 and that was important because I
had to play him in the movie and when he
was in his 20s and in his 50 and there
was no footage of that online so it was
it was good in terms of piecing it
together
tell me about working with Margo as a
boss Oh
yeah I mean it was you know it was great
I never I was never really that
conscious of her as a in that way and I
think maybe that's probably her doing
that job really well in the sense that
she was never bossy or you know at the
same time was jumping between acting and
producing back and forth a lot and I was
never able to see it so she did in such
an effortless ways and that it that it
shows you how good she was at it but um
I don't know I I love her I think she's
awesome
this week there's a story that Star Wars
fans want you to play Luke Skywalker oh
that's a really nice it's a really nice
story what and that Mark Hamill actually
supports that so what's your us him I my
reaction is when we shoot I'm all I'm
all for it whenever they want to go
let's do it okay last question Allison
Janney in every scene oh yeah yeah she's
amazing you know I yeah I mean I grew up
watching her in movies and I've always
loved her and and just to you know be
opposite of her was kind of like
watching a master at work and then and
then also it was really hard to keep a
straight face because she has so many
great lines and she was constantly
making us laugh with her improvisation
improvisation but I could not count how
many F words there were a lot or a lot